tom palisaro from the nfl network is
joining us to tell us all about
what he's heard what this day is going
to look like
tom ryan leaf here filling in for rich
how you doing buddy
busy ryan this is a unique draft for a
lot of different reasons
uh you know obviously on the day of
round one there is as you mentioned
always a lot of stuff
uh flying but just given the uncertainty
with the quarterbacks given the
uncertainty
uh in terms of the way the board breaks
in the first round uh i would anticipate
we are in for a 12 or so hours of
surprises
what uh what surprises today have you
heard
that you feel have some real validity
um because a lot of the stuff and what i
really do think is
today is a microcosm of what the last
three months have looked like you really
can't believe one word that's set out
there because we don't have any idea why
somebody's saying it
what their motivations are until they
actually step up to the podium
and make their pick well that's exactly
it
right now you have you know every team
and i've had you know brett for
you guys called and i hung up on your
producer the first time sorry about that
cause on the phone with the gm
everybody's trying to figure out what's
going on but it's not really going to
become in many cases
real until we see what happens for sure
at number three
because as much as everybody you know
has speculated in terms of
mac jones uh or trey lance what happens
at that spot is going to have a
trickle-down effect
on what happens uh elsewhere in the top
ten
who among the many teams that have been
trying to trade up into the top ten
whether that's the vikings the patriots
the eagles the saints
who is willing to make that type of move
and to give up the draft capital
uh there's just so many unknowns that
and again we could have a deal at any
point we've already seen
multiple deals in advance uh of the
draft people moving around the board
but a lot of the actions really gonna
occur within the round which is gonna
make for exciting tv on nfl network and
uh some other networks i won't mention
and but you know we may not know exactly
what that
what happens and how much of that talk
becomes reality until we get going
yeah i i agree with you there the 49ers
we know there's gonna be a quarterback
there i
i really think it it the dominoes that
could fall
really hinge on the falcons at four
because they become
are they still a team that is interested
in a quarterback or did arthur smith
when he got there find
that matt ryan is still the guy and they
can
either trade out of that spot and do a
lot of damage with some different draft
picks or they can take a guy there
and then you're talking about two
quarterbacks
now that fall can fall anywhere between
four
and well 20 probably
but if they decide to move out of that
spot or take a quarterback and you have
the one
of the five left you could see a bunch
of teams wanting to jump up there
to make sure they get the quarterback
before they're all gone
there's no question that five
quarterbacks are gonna go
in round one at this point i wouldn't
rule out seeing all five go
in the top ten just because of the
amount of
teams that are hovering and knowing
you've got teams like the panthers at
eight
and the broncos at nine that potentially
even after denver uh made a deal with
carolina yesterday for teddy bridgewater
and even after the panthers acquired sam
darnold those teams still
could be in the mix uh for quarterbacks
and that's why several days ago those
that was the hot spot seven eight nine
is where other teams were
uh calling around uh in terms of
potential trades
now in terms of atlanta uh you know
certainly they evaluated their options
you have to remember matt ryan
won the mvp five years ago playing a
very similar system to what arthur smith
is going to be installing
uh they have some weapons we know about
them getting calls on julio jones you
know their salary cap situation is not
ideal at all
at this stage uh we'll see whether or
not anything happens there
the prevailing thought within the league
in recent days has been that
if the falcons stay which it seemed and
again as of now
that they will simply because they've
been open to trade they've gotten calls
they've not gotten anything
uh that's made them to this point
consider moving the belief in the league
has been that they take florida tight
end
kyle pitts which if you still have julio
would potentially give you pits
julio and calvin ridley uh all on the
same team
and i talked with a coach about this
last night who was saying i understand
all these people are saying you got to
get rid of one of them
it's a great problem to have with the
way you can stress defenses with those
three guys even if it's for
uh just one year so you've got a lot of
young gm's
first-time gm's who are going to be
making some of these picks
you know trip trent balkin number one
with the jaguars has been a gm before of
course in san francisco but that's a new
program
with urban meyer you got a new coach at
number two and robert solo with joe
douglas who has not
drafted his own quarterback as sam
darnold was from the prior regime
how is he going to handle this the
falcons at four
terry fondo and arthur smith this is
their first time uh going through this
and then at number seven you got brad
holmes uh
and dan campbell in detroit what are
they going to do scott federer is a new
gm2 with denver at eight
george payton at nine with the broncos
all of which is to say
a lot of times teams are evaluating the
track record of other people
for instance when howie roseman is
calling every team in the top ten
everyone goes that's howie he calls
every team every year about every pick
maybe he moves up but maybe that's him
doing his due diligence
with all these new gm's who are looking
you know to make impactful moves
especially in the top
ten it really puts a lot of chips on the
table
in these situations especially when
you've got five quarterbacks that
depending on what team you're talking to
uh somebody's got them evaluated as
potential franchise guys
we're talking to tom pelicero from the
nfl network sirius xm
radio post as well uh big day
what teams outside the top 10 are you
looking at or focused on
that are really trying to make an effort
to get up there and move inside the top
ten
to take a guy that they feel like they
need
well again the eagles have been making
those calls for days uh over and over
we'll see whether anything comes of it
uh certainly there have been rumblings
that they would be among the other teams
the belief has been
they might be taking a defensive player
a corner uh you know maybe quitty pay
but you know gm's don't call and tell
the other teams who they're taking so
that's largely speculative
the vikings have made a lot of calls
potentially one of the offensive tackles
slides that could be somebody they're
targeting
the patriots have called up and down the
top ten looking for their possibility to
get in
the belief among the other teams have
gotten those calls is their guy
i would be justin fields and then i
mentioned the saints i know ian
rappaport first reported that this
morning that they've been calling
about moving up potentially even into
the top ten
there's a variety of different
directions that can go they are always
aggressive they don't mind bundling
picks and ending up with fewer draft
picks overall
to go up and get one guy they like they
did with marcus davenport
a couple of years ago they've done it in
other cases i would not surprise me at
all
if they get involved to move up but the
other thing is again going back to just
because you don't know what happens at
three you don't know who
is going to begin to slide you don't
know what's going to happen necessarily
at four or five either do the bengals
take jamar chase
or do they take pine sol if they take
pine sol all of a sudden the dolphins
are sitting there staring at jamar chase
or potentially
being able to trade down with somebody
who really wants to go up and get chase
there's all sorts of directions this can
go and the pivot point really begins
with what happens at that number three
pick speaking of that number three pick
it belongs to the san francisco 49ers
we're talking to tom pellicero from the
nfl network
about today's nfl draft so
jimmy garoppolo's name of course has
been drug around
uh since they've moved up to this spot
uh initially jimmy's their their planned
quarterback whoever they get is going to
learn
but uh we're hearing some rumblings
around him
possibly being on the trade block again
rumors today where do we stand with
jimmy garoppolo
as the 49ers starting quarterback and
will that continue to be
in 2021 well my understanding has been
you can anticipate multiple teams are
going to be checking in with the 49ers
about a potential trade the one team
that's obvious on paper has been linked
to this forever is garoppolo's old team
uh the patriots but you've got some
complicating factors
in any potential jimmy g deal because
the 49ers for one thing
are not going to give garoppolo away he
could still depending who they take in
number three
be their week one starter he also has a
no trade clause
that actually kicked in last month it
didn't exist in the first three years of
his contract
but it does as of the beginning of the
league year last month
and he'd also do 25.5 million dollars in
2021
so all he has to do to scuttle any deal
is not agree to restructuring his
contract
that's a lot of moving parts it would be
challenging
for the 49ers to move him unless it
would be part of potentially
a bigger deal where some high price
player is going back
to the 49ers nothing imminent there have
been no discussions
i am told about uh negotiating a new
contract elsewhere which would basically
be a prerequisite
to doing this deal but that is going to
be absolutely one of the things
to watch over the coming days we already
got one quarterback trade yesterday with
teddy bridgewater
being dealt to denver anytime that of
course was a product of sam darnold
being acquired by the by the panthers
anytime that you've got
players joining teams there is going to
be some veterans who suddenly come
available
the biggest challenge perhaps of all for
moving any player whether that is
you know julio jones zach hurts
uh any of the other names that we've
heard in recent months
because the salary cap is down as much
as it is this year
it's even trickier for teams to acquire
a high priced player nobody wants to
take on
salary right now it doesn't mean that
they can't but you're talking about pay
cuts and restructures
other things that are complicated
remember you cannot
execute a trade for a player if you do
not have the salary cap space
you can't say well we're gonna
restructure no you need to have that
worked out
or else the guy counts immediately
against your cap and you're in violation
so any of those types of deals
with veteran players if they're going to
happen they can't happen
while teams are on the clock unless
you're a team that's sitting there with
a mountain of cat space
yeah i mean you can't you're gonna be
able to restructure move things around
in 15 minutes before your
commissioner gets up and announces that
pick speaking of which and you can't
physical a guy
right you can't have the medical
autometers you run the wrist somebody
comes in
fails their physical you gave up a 2021
draft pick
now you got to figure out what to do
getting 2022 compensation
it's not ideal for anyone which is why
these deals need to get done in advance
speaking of making that draft pick all
right you talked about it you said
uh the first round hinges on on what the
49ers do and who they choose
now before i ask you who that's going to
be
there's been speculation after kyle
shanahan's press conference the other
day that they moved up
with no idea who who they were going to
draft right it was a
mat all five guys were very capable we
know trevor lawrence and zach wilson are
going one and two that's been
highly debated uh and been put to rest a
while ago
it's between three guys um and they knew
who they loved when they moved up
if they didn't then that's a
dysfunctional organization
you if you're gonna make that much
movement that many waves in a decision
to move up and draft
that high you know who you love and who
you're going to draft so they
they know and they've known for a while
what do we know who do they draft
tonight third overall
you're right that they had a very good
idea at the time they made the move who
they would be comfortable
taking mac jones from alabama from
everything i understand was
the guy who was the easiest fit into
their offense because he is a quick
processor
he is accurate those the two traits kyle
shanahan looks
for more than anything else and alabama
runs a variation of the same system so
much like
jack wilson who we believe is going to
be
most likely even though we course we
can't tip picks but every expectation
is that he'd be the jets ticket number
two he also ran a variation of that same
offense
at byu it's much easier to project what
quarterbacks are going to be as you know
well ryan
if you've seen them on tape making all
the throws and doing all the things
you're going to ask them to do
in the nfl but because they made the
49ers made that trade as early as they
did
they had a chance to go in see justin
fields live
see trey landslide alive get to know
those guys do zooms with them
and it certainly sounds in trey lance's
case in particular
as if he was very impressive which is
not surprising
of all the quarterbacks all the players
in this entire draft
there is nobody based upon all the
conversations i've had with coaches
uh with general managers with scouts who
grades out
higher in terms of the intangibles and
the overall makeup
than trey lance you know trevor lawrence
we've watched for three years
everybody knows what he is he has
everything checks every box as well
that's not the downgrade lawrence or any
other quarterback
in the draft but there are rare
qualities with trey lance that
the 49ers are not the only team in
intrigued by very early in the process
everything i heard from scouts was watch
this guy rise through the process
because whatever you see in terms of
holes on tape and a big one for coaches
is trey lance's accuracy
especially if you started in the first
exposure was that central arkansas game
where
he did not play well he did not throw
the ball well but the
the more time you spent with him from an
intelligence
football iq work ethic drive
all those things everything lines up
with trey lance where as one called
scouting director put it to me
who just said it was brutal watching
that tape but he goes
whatever his feeling is
he's going to get there so it's a
difference between with mac jones
betting on the high floor
low ceiling you know what he is he's the
most pro ready
according to teams or do you bet on the
potential low floor
a potential high ceiling with the tray
land and those are big time
organizational decisions that i don't
blame any team
for going through every single step of
the process and figuring out
whether or not you've got the right guy
you didn't mention justin fields
and i i want to ask you this last
question before we let you go
and get on your way um why why hasn't
he been in the mix he has all those
things you talked about a very high
ceiling
uh he's played uh an incredible
schedule over the last two years and one
of the highest uh
highest universities you can imagine in
terms of competition never lost a big
ten
football game why why is he continued to
slide and why isn't he a reasonable
answer for the 49ers
at three i would be i would say
ryan it's too soon to say that justin
fields is going to slide there are a lot
of people particularly coaches
who love justin fields we all know what
the questions were going into the
process
it was about processing he's coming from
an ohio state office that limits what
the quarterback
has to read it raise some questions on
tape but everyone at ohio state
vouches for him the coaches i've talked
to have spent time with justin field say
yeah he hasn't been asked to do certain
things
but do i think he can do it yes it was
also about some of the early things you
heard
from a leadership perspective going back
to twenty nineteen when he transferred
from georgia
didn't really get to know his teammates
all that well was just solely focused on
winning the job
but the word on that improved out of the
school in twenty twenty that he did step
forward in a leadership role he got
praised for starting the petition
to bring back fall football in the big
ten and we've obviously seen him take
some big shots like he did against
clemson
things that would wipe out some other
guys come back in and play well
you like all those traits with justin
fields so
the way that i have broken this down
from the beginning and
ryan i will be honest with you i have
watched one lick of tape outside the
highlights i see an nfl network i don't
know what i'm looking at
i'm not a scout i'm not a former
quarterback i just know what people in
the league think
and the way that the consensus breaks
down
within the league and this was before
the process as well as now the word
right at the end of the process with the
draft beginning tonight it was trevor
lawrence one
zack wilson a close to then you had a
group of three quarterbacks in justin
fields trey lance and mack jones
we're going to be ranked differently by
every team i guarantee you
their teams have justin fields as the
number three quarterback
if not higher than that on their board
consensus
lawrence one wilson two those three guys
are the next three
in some order but they're going there's
going to be variance just like there is
in that next group with the day two
quarterbacks of kellem on
davis mills and kyle pressed those three
are going to be ranked differently
on every different board and that's the
beauty of the draft it's about fit
it's about whether you bet on the
intangibles
it's about obviously the physical traits
that are going to jump out with some of
these guys
more than others and mac jones is not
going to look as good with his shirt off
as trey lance and justin field that is
just the fact of the matter but he
brings other things to the table
and if he ends up being the 49ers pick
at number three
it's because when kyle shanahan looks at
him and he is in full control
in san francisco it's the processing
it's the accuracy it's his belief that
that's the best guy who gives him the
best chance
to have a great deal of success in san
francisco well we all know who didn't
look good
in a picture at the nfl combine who
ended up going to in the new england
patriots and
sitting in josh mcdaniel's offense i
like mac jones if he slides
to 15 for the new england pages we're
talking to tom pelicero from the nfl
network thanks tom
we really appreciate your time you can
follow him on twitter at
tom pellicero nfl network provides live
coverage of the 220
2021 nfl draft starting tonight at 8 00
pm
eastern thanks so much for the insight
tom
thanks for having me ryan you bet hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here